man you wouldn't believe what they
charge for fuel out here I might
actually lose money on this job my
connection is making us wait
this negotiation tactic trust me this is
my specialty
yours is more
stab stabbed those are my terms
my father didn't stress diplomacy Thanos
he's not my father
when Thanos took my home world he killed
my parents in front of me
he tortured me turned me into a weapon
and he said he was going to destroy an
entire planet for Ronin like
I couldn't stand behind
why would you risk your life for this
the mother gave it to me
my mom liked sharing with me all the pop
songs that she loved growing up I happen
to have it on me when I was
the day that she
you know when I left Earth
what do you do with it do nothing you
listen to it
or you can dance I'm a warrior and an
assassin I do not dance
really
well on my planet
there's a legend about people like you
it's called
Footloose
and in it
a Great Hero
named Kevin Bacon
teaches an entire city full of people
with sticks up their butts that dancing
wow
it's the greatest thing there is
sticks up their butts what no that's
just uh
phrase people
use
[Music]
the melody is Pleasant since I met your
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
love
[Music]
I know who you are Peter Quill and I am
not some story I'd wait here to succumb
to your your public sorcery
and it's happening
no